we can go to the training post it was my
crib the Trading Post was your crib we
are going to be logging into Neopets for
the very first time in 15 years oh my
gosh you've never played Neopets before
well let me tell you you were missing
out because it was fun it had games
it had parenting that you have a pet and
you play games without the pet and then
you justify things for this pet who
doesn't really speak or talk I think it
was like the first time I was really
addicted to the Internet I played
probably around 10 to 15 hours a week
for 4 to 5 years God all right we are
logging in my username was xx cutie
dancer girl five six seven eight Tara is
core 18 beavers X on X fire I don't know
why my parents like didn't ever want to
get a pet so the closest thing I could
get to a pet was on neopets that was
always weird like what kind of [ __ ]
animals were these like when you look
back this is really weird
their names are bombed the names are
awesome I freaking love the names pixie
is hungry I know [ __ ] okay how do I
feed her alright now we are going to our
bank oh my god she has 2.3 million neo
points
I think neo coins were the precursor to
Bitcoin yes definitely can we talk about
the fact that there is a neo peon
inflation rate there's like a real
economy in here Oh jerk decided to hack
into my account he started asking me
these questions that I answered until I
realized that he was asking me for like
the answers to my recovery password
question the first support order itself
i got hacked i was like i'm gonna pick
myself up i will work twice as hard and
i'm gonna make it big and i sort of did
I guess I played murk Shay's at least a
hundred times a day it's so addicting
cuz you're like you know you could do
better you know you can do better you
know you can do better
now I'm gonna spin the wheel of
excitement it's been a long time
oh I [ __ ] love meatball didn't make
my ball team in real life but best
believe I was killing it with the menses
oh I'm I'm trying to talk to you I can't
be talking to you right now I'm gonna
play game oh oh so I'm gonna log you out
ANCA cuz you're gonna play this forever
cuz we awaken them at least I'm like
smiling a lot right now because this
reminds me of something like happy
memories of me enjoying my Neopets
okay Neil has made me into what I am
today what is you still felt like you
were going to get a burrito at the snack
shop or you were going to invest your
money into a stock market doesn't mean
time me and my Neopets just exploring
this world on her own it's us against
the world like no regrets at all so I
miss Neopets a lot like I think it's
great it was a safe space for me until I
got half the law so let's know that's
the very little did you see how much
money I had okay all right I'm probably
never gonna log in again